breaking news tonight The Washington
Post is now reporting that former FBI
director Andrew McCabe has been fired
yes the embattled former FBI director is
you know we know what happened with him
we know that his wife obviously was
running for State Representative got
help from Terry McAuliffe of course his
PAC donated hundreds of thousands of
dollars to her campaign it was not
revealed at the time and that raised a
huge problem and he's been in battled
now for you know several months a lot of
us thought he would have been fired a
long time ago remember his pension he
would have kicked in his pension on
Sunday
yet if he's fired today looks like that
pension will not kick in San Francisco
attorney Harmeet Dylan who's also the
national committeewoman for the
Republican National Committee for
California is with us now Harmeet
breaking news tonight I mean this this
really should have happened a long time
ago I don't know why they wait until two
days before he would retire and his
pension would kick in but nevertheless
this is the news tonight your reaction
well I agree with you Laura I think this
should have been done a while back and
the FBI director Ray has already taken
steps to remove mccabe from any
positions of authority but I guess the
triggering event here is the Office of
Professional Responsibility
investigation of recommendation and I
guess the Attorney General did not want
to act until he had that recommendation
in hand and make the decision himself so
I'm glad this action has been taken
clearly mr. McCabe was at the heart of a
number of troubling controversies at the
FBI starting before the election and
then continuing through today so maybe
this is the beginning of some reckoning
happening at the FBI would this head
rolling and of course there are others
Alisa Paige Peter struck and others who
were involved in the yeah we have the
Peter Stratton News yeah we have the
speed of Peter struck news that we're
also going to get to his relationship
with the judge who has since recused
himself let's go to Alan Dershowitz
professor Dershowitz this just broke
minutes ago the Washington Post McCabe
is out your reaction well I want to see
the evidence of the evidence
conclusively demonstrates that he was
less than candid and mislead
investigators then the firing seems
justified but I think you have to have a
fairly high threshold to fire somebody
on the eve of his retirement and take
away a pension that he's earned over a
long long period of time it's a good
service so yeah yeah I want to see this
I want to see the evidence that the
evidence justifies it fine as far as
struck is concerned that seems to be an
open-and-shut case for firing struck at
a minute let's hold that separately
because that's a separate issue
involving the judge in the case which
again this comes out today after
investigative reporter Sarah Carter
breaks the story which I mean it's like
we keep saying every day it can't get
worse but it keeps getting worse
joining us now we're delighted she's
with us is Sarah Carter who broke this
story about Peter Struck's friendship
with the judge in the case Sarah we were
talking just a few minutes ago in the
hallway you said keep your eye out for
the McCabe firing it could happen you
have good sources and justice because it
did happen tell us what led to this
happening two days before he would have
gotten his pension I mean it seems a
little odd that it would be happening
this late why did it take this long for
the Office of Professional
Responsibility to come to this decision
okay the Office of Professional
Responsibility OPR did come to the
decision that they wanted him fired
after after Michael Horowitz uncovered a
lot of information on Andrew became
Inspector General's exactly the
Inspector General at the DOJ and that
was then referred to OPR and I think
there's a lot of extenuating
circumstances here I don't think we've
heard everything I think there's a lot
more than just misleading the IG and the
FBI and also leaks which is what has
been reported right so we don't we only
know a little bit you must give us the
two or three things that are the most
egregious that have been out there that
called into question his professionalism
and handling his job oh I think
certainly the leaking to the media
number one now also the fact that he
lied he basically lied to the FBI to his
own employers and to the IG and I think
that Wow about
about his relationship actually and his
friendships was struck about what was
happening with the Hillary Clinton email
investigation and remember he he gave
that information to the Wall Street
Journal apparently he authorized that
and when they broke that story and then
he went back in the IG said hey were you
responsible for authorizing these leaks
he said no that's according to sources
that I've spoken with but I think this
goes far beyond that I think they're
also looking at possible criminal
charges and that's a very serious Wow
Alan Dershowitz and parmi let's go to
Harmeet first criminal charges against
Andrew McCabe this is a second time I've
heard this today
the earlier time was about two o'clock
in the afternoon from one of my sources
in the Justice Department today that
said you all know just a little bit of
what's gone on with Andrew McCabe again
20-year veteran of the department very
well-respected for years and yet
apparently we don't know what the OPR
knows and what the Inspector General
knows I will be finding out in the
coming days Harmeet yes I would have to
agree with Sara it seems hard to believe
that he would get fired for simply the
leaking although the leaking is
obviously very egregious the Wall Street
Journal story that came out that was the
product of those leaks was you know
clearly attempted to paint his role in a
different light than was true and a lot
of other politic and going on in that
story so that was pretty shocking but
this seems like turnabout is fair play
in a way we all know we've seen the
stories about how you know general Flynn
has been indicted and asked to plead
guilty on on charges of a lie to the FBI
and where you have the FBI number three
in command and temporarily number one in
command lying himself to other FBI
agents it seems appropriate to hold them
to the same standard professor
Dershowitz again this is this is wild on
a Friday night two days before a man who
served the government for decades and
was very well-respected before the
Hillary email investigation I think took
place to be fired in this way I have to
I have to take Sarah in her reporting to
Hart here I don't think they would risk
firing him were it not for some fairly
serious
information that has come to light and
that will be reported in the I defy the
IG that sounds right to me
this afternoon I was saying that I think
there has to be a high burden before you
fire somebody who's performed in a
distinguished way for 20 years but I
have a lot of experience with the OPR
the Office of Professional
Responsibility they don't generally go
after their own they generally whitewash
their own and when the OPR comes to this
conclusion you really have to give it
some credibility I still want to see the
evidence but I bet you will see evidence
that's far more compelling than what
we've heard about up to now and when
they're talking about criminal charges
that sounds very very serious it's
distressing because I had a lot of
respect for McCabe based on what people
who have worked in the FBI have told me
over the years but you can't have a
double standard you have to have the
same standard for a Democrat for a
Republican for people who have been in
the FBI and for civilians and and if
that standard has been met for criminal
prosecution and for firing so be it and
folks we just got the Attorney General's
statement which I'm going to read he
writes the FBI expects every employee to
adhere to the highest standards of
honesty integrity and accountability as
the OPR proposal stated all FBI
employees know that lacking candor under
oath results in dismissal and that our
integrity is our brand pursuant to
Department order 1202 and based on the
report of the Inspector General the
findings of the FBI Office of
Professional Responsibility and the
recommendation of the department's
senior career official I have terminated
the employment of Andrew McCabe
effective immediately he goes on to say
the FBI expects every employee to adhere
to the highest standards of honesty
integrity accountability and then he
went on to say both the Office of
Inspector General General and the OPR
reports concluded that McCabe had made
an unauthorized disclosure to the news
mate media sarah said and lacked candor
under oath on multiple occasions so this
this seems in the way it's working just
seems like an open-and-shut case
you cannot make
you cannot make exceptions even for
someone with a very distinguished career
as a civil servant as a career
professional you know people make
mistakes for a variety of reasons or
people do things for a variety of
reasons I'm not going to try to get into
his head but I do not think the Office
of Professional Responsibility in
sessions with all of the media spotlight
on them would take this action were it
not very serious